thank you for coming and I'm shakir and
really excited to talk to you today
about unsupervised learning and
generative model so I wanted to maybe
just start with a quick question to all
of you few people want to shout out
maybe the reasons they think
unsupervised learning is important in
machine learning generative models may
be important or maybe if we have someone
contrarian who thinks they aren't
important everyone wants to throw up at
the back so if you don't have enough
label data to do supervised learning
that's a great one another any other
reasons or thoughts around what a
generative model is the applications
while we let people settle in anyone
else
ok so pardon using NLP used in NLP yes
to do natural language generation of
text or even audio or other kinds of
things so well experiment and explore a
lot of the different ways of generative
models and unsupervised learning more
generally I think you haven't seen
anything around unsupervised learning
thus far in this course but you've
probably seen them we know this and so I
thought we'd start with that so what the
person said at the back why are we
interested in unsupervised learning and
the first reason that many people give
is to move beyond associating simply
inputs to outputs of images or features
to labels or to targets but then there
are other kinds of reasons like the
example that was just given around in
elpida we want to understand how the
world is evolving how it's going to
change over time and we want to be able
to imagine and simulate these kind of
potential evolutions of the world going
forward in time there are these things
which we recognize as people that are
objects in the world they are objects
like your computer like paper like a
screen they have certain ways in which
they are move they behave their factors
are variation as they call them which we
want to know related to that is we want
to be able to do a more abstract kind of
reasoning and
so in this kind of abstract reasoning we
want to be able to establish certain
types of concepts a conceptual basis for
the world and do reasoning and
decision-making in that space we want to
be able to know when something is new is
interesting is surprising and we want to
be able to generate plans about the way
we will behave in the future the way
you're doing reinforcement learning so
all of these are the reasons why we are
interested in unsupervised learning and
I hope maybe we'll try and explore some
of all of these kinds of things as we go
through so but unsupervised learning
will just be one part of far more bigger
suite of things that really imagine and
under various different names but one
way to think of them are as
complementary learning systems we have
several different types of learning
systems unsupervised supervised
reinforcement learning semi-supervised
other kinds of transductive learning
then will all work together to
complement each other for us to build
these general-purpose learning systems
right and so when we come to generative
models are usually group their
applications in their roles in three
different areas we want to have
generative models because we want to
build products we want to build things
which are useful which help our everyday
lives so things like super resolution of
images and video as we want to do
transmission and compression of high
bandwidth data streams we want to do
text-to-speech for example to create
accessibility tools then we want to move
to areas of science we want to continue
to understand how it is that the natural
and physical world observes and then to
do use those scientific basis to again
inform other kinds of areas like
healthcare and the social social world
so things like proteomics drug discovery
understanding celestial objects using
high-energy physics where the big
question in high-energy physics is how
we move beyond the standard model that's
what they call the current question now
that we've found the Higgs boson what is
beyond that standard model and then we
have the tasks of reasoning and AI so
can we do planning how do we do
exploration as agents in the world to
discover new
here is how do we build self motivation
and keep ourselves discovering new
things and maybe part of what you've
seen in the other half is around doing
model-based reinforcement learning so
these are all some of the different
areas that I have in mind and different
products so I'm gonna do a little
experiment with you but I thought we're
gonna do two halves and in this first
half
I thought we'd look at five tricks for
manipulating probabilities and I'm gonna
just discuss with you five
self-contained tools mathematical and
probabilistic tools that you can use in
almost every part of machine learning
and they're typically 4 4 into 3 parts
one part will be about manipulating
integrals another part will be about
manipulating densities and another part
of up manipulating gradients and these
five tricks together you can use them
certainly for generative models what
we're going to discuss in the next part
but you have already used some of them
in reinforcement learning and in other
areas of machine learning that you've
covered before you've used them and I
want to just represent them to you in a
different light and then in the second
part we'll do a brief introduction to
generative models we'll look at the
types of generative models that we have
available and then we'll break
generative models up into two parts
prescribed generative models and
implicit generative models and we'll
look at the different kinds of ways of
doing learning in these two types of
models so ok here my five tricks and
again I want you to try and experiment
with you because I want to try and do
this again later on at the machine
learning summer school so please give me
feedback at the end as to how you think
it worked out so the thing that I want
to leave you in this first half of this
next 50 minutes is that I want each and
every one of you to be able to build a
probabilistic dexterity when you see
probabilities and integrals and
probabilities you can manipulate and
mould them to do the things that you
need to do and this is effectively the
problem of machine learning so if we
have this probabilistic dexterity if we
have a set of tools which we can
manipulate integrals probability
distributions and their gradients then
we will have the tools to solve the
fundamental problems of machine learning
in AR and some of these questions come
up one of the most fundamental questions
is always to compute the evidence of a
set of data so if
data X you want to know what is the
probability that that dataset appears in
the world and knowing this quantity is
in fact one of the most fundamental
quantities you can know in machine
learning because if you know this
probability X you basically know
everything you know when it's surprising
what is probable you know all its
moments you know you can do everything
from there rewriting this evidence
estimation question in a different way
so this first part is sometimes called
the marginalized probability they
integrated likelihood the partition
function that has several different
kinds of names you may want to do a
simpler task than this you may just want
to compute a set of moments this is
because you want to summarize data in
some way you want to compute this
quantiles or certain expect Isles and
knowing those quantities and reporting
them is useful and so for example
physics you want to do Six Sigma
computations of whether something is
actually there or not so then you'll
want to do these moment computations
where you'll compute an expectation of
some function of a random variable the
the notation is swapping around but just
use it as a general idea of course the
most fundamental problem in machine
learning statistics is to do parameter
estimation you want to actually know
what the value of parameter theta of a
model that you have is given some data X
and if you want it to be frequentist
then you will find the point estimate
and a confidence interval around theta
or if you are being Bayesian you would
find the entire probability distribution
and report either its central central
area and then it's a confidence highest
probability density region so this is
probably the most common what you've
done almost in every course in machine
learning so far and of course we want to
do prediction because once we have these
models we want to use it to do something
useful in the world the thing you've
seen in the other part is to do planning
so that if you have a certain cost
function C and an action u that you are
trying to take how is it that you can
choose the set of actions you to
maximize the cost under certain types of
probability distribution so this was the
fundamental equation that you were all
solving to talk about man's equation and
to learn the policy gradient theorem and
to do value estimation as well
then another kind of important one is
for example if we are dealing with
medical domain you will have multiple
hypotheses that we are testing and you
need to be able to compare those two
hypotheses which one is better or which
one has the effects that you wanted it
to have and then the last one relate to
the hypothesis testing is to do an
experimental design how is it that I can
take an action observe what happens in
the world and then choose the actions of
the next set of experiments that I will
do so that I actually learn and so
hidden in all of these things there are
a probabilities and these probabilities
are sometimes difficult you don't know
what they are sometimes you are known to
you partially sometimes you can only
simulate you don't know them
analytically in almost all of them there
is a horrible integral it's just written
one here but usually it's a
d-dimensional integral over the
dimension of things that you are dealing
with so you can't solve it numerically
in other cases they are gradients which
need to be done through inverse
probabilities and there are other
normalizing constants that appear or in
some cases that external factors which
are affecting your model and so in all
of these cases you will need to do some
kind of manipulation and this is where
this first part is and if we have those
kind of tricks we can manipulate all
these integrals all these gradients all
these probabilities and then we can
actually build a rich very rich and deep
understanding of machine on so the first
trick I wanted to present you you've all
seen this before it's called the
identity trick so whenever you have a
problem that you have an integral or an
expectation in some distribution P you
may not like that integral you may not
like P P is not your friend you can
instead change the integral into an
expectation under a different
distribution q here is something you get
to choose q is your friend so this is
where you will use this identity trick
and so here's the expectation you have
an integral of some probability
distribution x over a function f of X Y
it's the expectation of X under the
distribution P as I said you may not
like this integral for various reasons
because P is difficult to compute
because F may be not differentiable for
various reasons and you instead want to
rewrite it as an expectation like this
an expectation under a new distribution
Q with some transformation of the
function f so
writing this G here and writing out the
integral and so how you move between
these two is to multiply your
probabilities by one right so we're
going to introduce a probabilistic one
and I think you've seen this already at
least in two different places so let's
do let's apply this identity trick so
here's an integral problem I want to
compute the expectation of this
distribution P of X given Z under the
distribution P of Z so that's our
integral problem and typically if you
had studied graphical models before we
had have seen this kind of latent
variable problem has appeared before
right and so the trick is to multiply
this integral by one so I'm going to
introduce this new distribution Q and Q
divided by Q is 1 so the integral is
exactly the same right but now I can
regroup the terms I can leave P of x
given Z and I can group P of Z divided
by Q of Z as some new quantity and
actually this ratio is something just to
keep in mind we'll look at it a bit
later and now there's a new distribution
Z and now this is an integral which is
an expectation under the distribution Q
of this new quantity right and so this
trick you can use almost everywhere and
it's one of the most useful tricks
you'll use it in reinforcement learning
to do sort of policy Corrections you
will use it in the next slide so there's
just some things to know because we are
dividing by Q you need to make sure that
Q is greater than zero wherever this
product of P times P is greater than
zero and Q that you are into introducing
and choosing must be something you
should easily manipulate right and so
this trick is obviously the basis of
important sampling that you've seen
before where we call the ratio P divided
by Q the importance weight which is W
you can simulate a sample from Q of Z
and then you can evaluate this integral
by Monte Carlo integration right and
this is one of the most useful tools to
keep in mind this to of integration by
using Monte Carlo an important something
is one of the most basic tools we have
for manipulating probabilities but it is
useful only if you want to know the
value of an integral right because
that's what important sampling does if
you wanted to do more than know the
value of an integral if you wanted to
use it for learning then important
sampling is not going to be quite useful
but we'll come to that a bit later on so
you would have seen this kind of
identity trick not just an important
sampling you will of you we will use it
again later on to manipulate certain
stochastic gradients if you are doing
sort of probability theory you will
always use this trick to derive certain
types of bounds to show the convergence
properties and asymptotic properties of
their convergence and then if you're
actually dealing with a reinforcement
learning where you're thinking of off
policy Corrections then you will always
introduce these kind of ratios which
will appear to handle these kind of
settings so this is a very useful trick
to have in mind the next kind of trick
is the bound and trick and there's so
many bounding tricks that I just chose
the most general one to do and I'll
mention a few others at the end but one
of the most important results from
convex analysis is that you can always
take the function of an expectation can
be bounded by the expectation of a
function for functions f that are
concave right and this is super useful
because sometimes dealing with the
function of an expectation is difficult
to do and you want to swap the integral
with the function that's coming up there
and of course this is equal if the
function is linear because expectation
is linear but for other functions you
won't have this probability so logs are
the one we will always be interested in
or most often interesting because we
want to use log probabilities for
numerical reasons and for simplification
of the additive property and so we will
always take the log of this integral
which is the log of an expectation is
the expectation of the log and this will
be is also used almost everywhere you
would have seen this in optimization of
course because you are deriving what
they ask what the rates of convergence
of optimization algorithms are we're
going to talk about variational
inference and variational inference is
derived on this quantity and if you've
studied Monte Carlo Markov chain Monte
Carlo in other courses then you would
have proven that there Monte Carlo
integrators or Markov chain Monte Carlo
methods can have lower variance
under what using raw Blackwell's theorem
and the crux of our Blackwell theorem is
to use this form of Jensen's inequality
and there are many other ways of
building kinds of bounds of
probabilities this way the other very
useful one is to use central duality and
now the tool that we get from convex
analysis then when you can turn use your
central jewel then you can get another
bound which will always be convex and
bound the probability and then that will
be useful for doing various kinds of
other variational methods holders
inequality which just helps you do
products of probabilities into their
products of the individual norms is
always useful and many of you have heard
about optimal transport and integral
probability metrics and that's where
this famous Monch kantorovich inequality
comes in which helps you derive yet
other kinds of bounds of probabilities
and these three together and when you
put all of them together you can build
very flexible kinds of tools so the next
one is about evidence bounds so we want
to actually use this trick that we just
used so again this is the integral
problem I want to compute the evidence P
of X which will be the integral of this
likelihood function P of X given there
again some distribution P of Z now I can
introduce this identity trick again by
multiplying by Q and dividing by Q and Q
of Z was the proposal distribution in
important sampling but here it may have
a different name well recreate the
importance way to P divided by Q
multiplied by Q and when we did
importance sampling at this point we
said we're going to solve the integral
by using Monte Carlo integration but now
we're not going to solve the integral by
Monte Carlo we're instead going to apply
Jensen's inequality and so Jensen's
inequality so now do this on the log of
everything so add a log on both sides
the log of P of X will be greater than
the expectation on the Q of the log of
this quantity and the inside right so
just read that again now this is an
integral and expectation of a Q of Z of
this joint log probability and so we can
just split that using the property of
the log to an integral of the log
probability P of X given Z minus the
integral of this log ratio Q of Z
divided by P of Z and this of course is
a very famous lower bound it has very
several several names but it will be
called the evidence lower bound in this
case
it's often called the variation of free
energy or just a variational lower bound
but what we can talk about that more in
the next section but just the point is
to know that this is now a bound on the
original quantity and knowing bounds of
quantities is sometimes better than
knowing the quantity itself because you
know exactly what the minimum was and
you can do manipulations on this which
is easier than doing manipulations on
this and so this is where this kind of
trick of using bounds comes in and in
all those previous inequalities this is
the principle that when you use holders
inequality or when you use the central
dual to create a different kind of
bounds you got a new problem which is
actually simpler to deal with so I have
a fourth trick which is called the
density ratio trick and the density
ratio trick is is a very simple trick
there's often like you just saw an
important sampling there's always a
ratio that appears some ratio of two
quantities and this density ratio trick
says sometimes you aren't at the naive
way to compute the density ratio is to
compute the top part compute the bottom
part then do the division and then
that's why you get the number but that's
actually sometimes very difficult to do
and sometimes you aren't interested in
knowing those individual quantities you
only want to know the ratio directly so
often computing the ratio is easier than
computing the individual probabilities
and that's where this this trick comes
in and the trick simply says that if you
want to know the ratio you can just
build a classifier which will say
classify samples from the distribution P
style versus the samples from the
distribution Q star and if you can build
this classifier than that classifier has
all the information that you need to
compute the ratio of P divided by Q and
in fact you just need to do this ratio
of P of coming from class P to this is 1
minus P so not coming from class P I'll
show you we'll do the derivation in the
next line but this density ratio trick
is also one of the most famous tricks we
have in machine learning of course if
you've heard of generative adversarial
networks this is the core quantity or
the core idea underlying generates about
the cero Network but outside and if you
go a bit wider in machine learning a bit
outside of deep learning
then you'll find a method called noise
contrastive estimation and if you want
to derive the noise contrastive
estimator this is the trick that's being
used if you've been studying Markov
chain Monte Carlo methods there's a an
approach called approximate Bayesian
computation and one way of doing
approximate Bayesian computation is
using classifier by exploiting this
trick some of you would have done
hypothesis testing in the past and if
you want to do hypothesis testing then
one way of doing two sample hypothesis
testing is to use this kind of trick and
again any method where you have a
difference between the distribution at
test time versus training time what they
call the covariant or calibration
problem will do that is their question
yes okay so let's do the derivation and
then ask me this again are there any
other questions at this point or let's
do the derivation then we can have a
discussion around all these tricks so
okay let's do a reminder here's the
problem you're interested in there's the
density ratio of P divided by Q and it's
always useful to keep in mind Bayes rule
so Bayes rule it's just a rule to do
inverting probabilities so to invert the
probability of Y given X to the
probability of x given Y using the ratio
of the two marginals so what we're going
to do is we're going to sample data from
P star and sample data from Q of X and
we're going to call all the data from P
star x hat and all the data from Q X
tilde and we're going to put them
together into one big data set then
because we are manipulating the
probability we can always introduce the
label so for every data point we are
going to introduce a label and a new
random variable so we're going to
introduce this random variable Y and for
all the data that came from P star we're
gonna give it a label plus one and for
all the data that came from Q we're
gonna give the label minus one so that's
not enough to set up a classification or
a decision problem so there's an
equivalence by doing this construction
by construction P star of X can be
written as the probability of P of X
given the label y equals plus 1 because
that's how we defined it we said every
data point that came from what must be
from P and similarly from Q and then we
have this too so now you can see the
trick
gonna do P star of X divided by Q of X
can be rewritten as the ratio of these
two conditional distributions which are
equivalent in all forms now we're gonna
replace knowing P of X given Y is
actually not nice to use my Bayes rule
will help us to undo that so we're going
to do the base substitution and we're
going to replace all of this with
distributions of P of Y given X instead
so this is where the classification is
going to come in now I'm doing a slight
assumption here I'm assuming that the
probability of P of y equals 1 is equal
to the probability of P equals y equals
minus 1 so I'm assuming there's a
balance data set because I got to just
draw the samples from P and Q but if
they are not balanced then you will
actually have the ratio of the imbalance
which will be these two quantities and
then P of X and P of X is the same on
both sides because the data is invariant
and those two will cancel so then what
you're left with is this class
probability it says basically to compute
the ratio you just need to know the
ratio of the two class probability you
just need to know P of y equals 1 given
X divided by P of y equals -1 given X
right and so that is the point of this
trip it says computing a density ratio
is equivalent to compress tomato the
class probability estimation then you do
that so now coming to your question at
the end the thing that answers your
question is that you will do this
quantity for 1x but you will do this in
expectation over the whole data set or
over two different data sets and then
that's how you will use this for
learning so ok so that's basically this
density ratio trick and I have two last
tricks and then then let's summarize and
have a discussion about what these
tricks mean so that was about
manipulating densities and now I want to
go to the problem of manipulating
gradients themselves so one of the most
common problems in all of machine
learning in fact all of statistical
science whether you call it statistic
operations research in finance is to
compute this quantity you have an
expectation of a function and the
expectations with respect to some
distribution Q and you want to compute
the gradient of this course this
expectation but if you want to compute
the
radiant with respect to these district
these parameters Phi which live in the
distribution with which you're taking
the expectation so I'm just gonna
rewrite that integral out it's the
gradient of the integral of the
distribution Q what the parameter is Phi
that we are introducing in again some
function f that function may have some
other parameters that for the purpose of
this gradient computation we aren't
going to be interested in and if the if
all these were simple distributions that
linear functions and it's may be
one-dimensional you'd be able to compute
this integral very easily but in general
you won't know this be able to compute
the integral and if you don't know the
integral you can't compute the gradient
and that's because these are high
dimensional quantities and because
they're high dimensional you won't be
able to do the the gradient you won't
know the expectation in closed form
because typically you have nonlinear
functions and very complicated non
primitive distributions and the facts
what really makes it complicated is that
the gradient I introduced interested in
is with respect to these parameters Phi
and so we're going to need to do several
tricks to manipulate this but I just
wanted to point out where you would see
this integral so we're gonna talk this
integral is obviously one of the key
things to Jean learning in generative
models so we'll see in all the problems
of inference in generative models that
we use if you've already started down a
lot of reinforcement learning and
control and this is the key question to
computing the expected expectation under
your policy and doing policy learning in
the policy gradient a framework for
doing reinforcement learning in
operations research you would F is set
up the same problem of estimating a
queueing problem and then wanting to
know the probability or queueing rate
and then you would get the same kind of
question coming up if you're doing Monte
Carlo simulation in finance they
actually have a name for this gradient
it's some Greek alphabet Alpha Gamma
Delta it just depends which gradient you
are taking so all the finance is
basically about computing this integral
and they have entire textbooks just to
give us all the tricks to compute this
integral and actually in many other
areas of optimization they will call
knowing this quantity or doing this kind
of analysis sensitivity analysis so it's
really one of the most fundamental
things that we know a lot of tricks from
many other areas so they're to basically
two things you can do with an integral
like this we manipulate you do some
trick with F or you do some trick with Q
and basically this is everything that
you can do there are two other tricks
you can do on an integral like this but
not useful for us this machine learners
because we want to build scalable
large-scale easily easily codable
solutions so let's look at those two and
I'm going to call things where we
manipulate F a path wise estimator and
you'll see why we'll call it the
pathways estimator later and we'll call
things where we manipulate Q a score
function estimate and you also see why
that's the case so the first one is
based on the long term relative trick
and it's not really a trick because it's
basic basic calculus it says the
gradient of a log is just equal to that
quantity the gradient of the quantity
divided by itself right so the gradient
of a log must be this and you're just
going to use this fact that you can jump
between so why this is important is that
it takes you from gradients of a log
probability to gradients of a
probability so you can just jump back
and forth between these two things
whenever you like so and that kind of
manipulation is very flexible because it
lets you rewrite the integral in much
more interesting ways so it has several
useful properties which we've already
seen so if you have done a course in
statistics and you know what maximum
likelihood is which you all do then you
would obviously know this key quantity
that gradient of a log probability is
called the score and the expectation of
the score is always zero and this is why
we actually use it for and how you prove
this and this is part of building this
probabilistic flexibility you'll have to
derive it on paper now but eventually
you should all get to the point where
you see this thing and then you see well
oh obviously this is true because I can
replace this graded by Delta Q divided
by Q this Q that Q will cancel you take
the grade and outside of the expectation
the gradient the integral of a
distribution is one in the gradient of
something that's one is zero and that's
why this thing is it's true right and
this thing you have also seen if you
have started the policy gradient theorem
because this was the key thing that they
used to make sure that it was sensible
and then the other interesting property
of the score is that the variance of the
score is called the Fisher information
and this is one of the most important
quantities in all of
Nonnie because this is the claim or a
lower bound which is the minimum
variance estimator that you can get is
defining this in terms of this quantity
and so all of the properties of maximum
likelihood that we get come from this
just this simple using this simple trick
so let's use this trick to manipulate
that first integral that we have so
here's the integral and now it's the
gradient again of expectation of a
function f with respect to distribution
Q now I'm going to use the liveness
integral rule which means that I'm going
to swap the gradient in to the end the
integral and you can typically do that
for these probabilities because they're
all operate in the same domain
they're all continuous and so the kind
of conditions that you need are true and
I can point you to a much more deeper
paper if you actually want to see all
the the depths of actually why it is
that you can do that but and as I said
we are going to try and manipulate this
quantity Q so what I'm going to now if
the gradient goes inside so that's why
this gradient of Q times f I'm going to
use the identity trick again so I'm just
going to multiply by one now I'm going
to reform this ratio of Delta Q divided
by Q and then that basically using the
log derivative trick from above means
that this quantity is just the log the
gradient of the log probability and
exactly the reason why we use identity
tricks is that this now is the new
expectation with respect to Q this is an
expectation under the distribution Q of
this function f times the gradient of
the log probability right and I'm going
to do one more step which is I just said
to you the good and useful property was
that the expectations of this long
probability are zero and so I can
actually subtract any other quantity
some constant any constant C and because
that constant C is independent of the
parameters and the expectation of this
thing is zero it doesn't affect anything
that I'm doing but the thing that it
will affect is the gradient the variance
of this quantity and knowing the
variance in controlling the variance is
a whole area of statistics which is
called control variant estimation and
knowing how to choose see what the
optimal C is for your particular problem
is something you can design and
let me reax plain this equation to you
the way you learnt it in reinforcement
learning so in reinforcement learning q
is what you called the policy and you
wanted to compute the policy gradient
which is the gradient with respect to
the policy parameters which are Phi in
this case you had a reward function
which was log Q and then you call this
reinforce well the word function is f
sorry and then you have the gradient of
this log key which is the policy and so
then you said things that have high
reward f you will reinforce that
gradient and then you will send it up
and things that have low reward
F well then you will not reinforce and
then you will multiply that policy
gradient and then you also introduced
this thing called C what you called the
in had various names I don't you just
call it a base line I think in
reinforcement learning but in statistics
we will call this the control bears and
then you can design this and knowing
that in reinforcement learning you have
a particular n MVP you can design a C
for your MVP and if you were doing
finance problem where you were computing
a time series of returns of a stock then
you'll be able to compute a C using the
kind of auto regressive model you were
building for that sound so there's lots
of different names also some people
you'd like to call this the likelihood
ratio method I think that's a bad bad
name so don't ever call it that I'm just
telling you so when you Google you'll
sometimes see this and in some
reinforcement learning textbooks they
use this terrible naming then of course
you've seen a reinforcement reinforced
algorithm and the policy gradients are
built in this exact concept and then in
other areas like more in probabilistic
inference reinforcement learning they
would call the automated inference or
sometimes black box inference right
because this is a kind of black box in
to go and when will you want to use this
kind of integral you will use it when
this function f is not differentiable
because you don't need to differentiate
it all you need to be able to do is
evaluate the function f what you need to
do though is evaluate this expectation
so you will assume that Q is something
which is simple that you can sample from
and because you want to differentiate Q
you will need to be able to take its
derivative you will need to know it
analytically so almost all problems can
have this thing so this is usually the
first default way of approaching a
gradient estimator
so let's do a different trick and this
one has many different names but most
common today people call this the Reaper
amortization trick so every distribution
can be re-expressed as a function of
some other distribution or so let's do
this so I have a distribution Q of some
function of some random variable said
this distribution Q can always be
re-expressed in terms of a deterministic
function with some parameters v which
will transform another distribution
which will have some distribution
epsilon intercept so the simplest one to
do is to think of the inverse sampling
theorem you have a uniform distribution
all uniform distributions can be
transformed into another distribution
using the inverse CDF of the
distribution you are interested in right
and this was the first thing you learned
about probabilistic sampling and this is
if you always think in this uniform
setup you'll be able to derive the most
generic form of what this trick is but
typically we use other just slightly
more we don't use start to primitive
distribution as the uniform we use other
distributions like gaussians betas
bernoulliís etc and how I like to think
of that is more like a set of pipe so
you have some distribution which we
start off with which is this base
distribution P of Z and what I was
calling P of epsilon here sorry for the
mix-up and then you have to sort of
things which mix into this pipe you have
some parameters mu and some parameters R
and then they get mixed up through this
function R so the case of a Gaussian is
just mu plus R times ed and then once
you get out is a new distribution
instead and knowing this pipe in knowing
the configuration of the pipe is useful
for the gradient because you can follow
the path of this pipe backwards and it
is this reason because of this
transformation of this variable through
the path function G to get this new
random variable said that this the trick
that we're about to talk about will be
called path wise estimation or path wise
computation and so the main point of
Reaper ammeter ization trick like every
route parameterization is just the
change of variables rules for
probability and if we had more time I
would have done a whole trick just for
change of variables rules and sure
you instead of how they appear in
continuous and discrete spaces but we're
gonna skip that today but just know that
this is the rule for the change of
variables if you have a distribution
epsilon and you have some function that
changes epsilon to Z like here you can
know the distribution P of Z by
computing this gradient and multiplying
by the original thing this is you
learned this in calculus under the
change of variables and the rule is
identical when we come to it in
probability and we're going to use this
trick and just keep in mind that because
we are probabilities and we must exist
in a probability space where things must
integrate to one and volume is never
lost as a conservation property you can
always use this sort of loose notation
just to say the volume of probabilities
must be conserved that P Z times D Z
must always PE times de and you must
these things can be equal that's why you
can do manipulations by substituting
this for this so let's just do the trick
a bit of a non rigorous weird kind of
derivation but I think it will work so
again this is our integral problem it is
the integral of a distribution of a
function f against the distribution Q
and we want to know the gradients with
respect to Phi and you have a known
transformation which is G which
transform samples epsilon with
parameters Phi into Z so we're going to
do this change of variables now let's
write this a bit slowly just say you see
wherever you see that you can replace
that by the function G of epsilon comma
Phi because that is what the
substitution rule is and then I said
well Q of Z can be rewritten in terms of
epsilon using this change of variables
rule so it's P of epsilon which is the
base distribution times the derivative D
epsilon over D Z and there's this
gradient which is going to appear
because of the change of variables rule
so I'm also going to change DZ to D
Epsilon and the way you do DZ to D
epsilon is to know that these epsilon DS
there is equal to G prime and so again
this is where this volume is being
preserved right and then I'm going to
apply the inverse function theorem on
this derivative D epsilon by DZ and that
effectively is going to cancel out this
derivative here G Prime
and so G Prime will disappear and then
basically what you'll be left is with an
expectation on the P of epsilon instead
then of the function of G directly and
now actually the integral is over
epsilon which has nothing to do with Phi
so now you are free to take the gradient
directly through and you don't have to
worry about any there are no conditions
to check the gradient can just go
directly through the integral and so
this then is basically what is called
this path wise gradient estimator it
says that if you no change of variables
for Q you can then rewrite it through
this path wise gradient estimate of
Epsilon and a simpler distribution P of
epsilon of the gradient of the function
of the change of variables and this is
nice to do because now it's just back
prop you just can take the gradient of
fee of f through G to get to Phi right
and this is why in other papers we call
this stochastic back propagation it's
called the real parameterization trick
and for every other area of probability
outside of machine learning they will
call this the pathways estimate pathways
great and estimator so where you would
have seen this before is when you learnt
about the basics of expectation they
would have maybe mentioned this things
you call the law of the unconscious
statistician which is if you are given a
transformation how can you compute this
expectation under that transformation
and so you will see this is the point of
doing this change of variables as I
mentioned we call the stochastic back
propagation this idea of computing
gradients is where they could call this
perturbation analysis and under
perturbation analysis you can do derive
certain other variations of this
gradient
there's the reaper ammeter ization trick
and other people have called this a fine
independent inference and in fact this
trick is also used in Monte Carlo
sampling but I forget the name the name
of it I have a reference at the end so
when when should you use this kind of
gradient estimator so now you need to do
it much more you actually need to
differentiate through F so f you need to
be know F and F must be differentiable
again Q is a distribution with the
transform you need to be able to rewrite
Q of Z in terms of P epsilon and a
deterministic
function G and so these functions can be
anything can be the inverse CDF which is
how you'll derive the most generic form
of this root parameterization trick it
can be a location scale transform like
this function here for the Gaussian or
it can be any other kind of coordinate
transform that you have and then you
want to make sure that this base
distribution P epsilon is actually
something simple and easy to sample from
okay so that was basically five tricks
we looked at the identity trick and the
identity trick was a way of rewriting an
expectation from one distribution to
another this is the number one trick
it's the first thing you will probably
do for most everything so one of the
most useful things to know then we looks
at one bounding trick based on Jensen's
inequality but building bounds is one of
the most useful tricks for doing
learning and when you especially when
you want to build very large scale
learning algorithms that go to millions
and tens of thousands of parameters the
density ratio trick is a useful one
because like you saw an important
sampling like you see in reinforcement
learning like you saw in almost all the
other tricks there's always a ratio of
two distributions that appear and this
ratio can give you knowledge of how
things are we gonna look at that the log
derivative trick basically exploits the
the definition of what the gradient of
the log is to show the properties of log
likelihood functions and score functions
we showed the basis of maximum
likelihood and then we looked at three
parameter ization tricks which
effectively just deployed the rule for
change of variables of probability in
all different settings to help us derive
different kinds of gradient estimators
so basically the point of this half was
just to leave with you the message to
sharpen your probabilistic tools to
always search for those tricks that
means you can manipulate probabilities
in the right way and as these tricks
show that if you manipulate them you can
actually do very interesting kind of
things that transform what were
difficult problems that you could only
solve in 1d two things that you can work
on imagenet scale of data ok so that's
the end of the first half we can take a
10-minute break or have a discussion on
any questions around what we discussed
in the first half are there any thoughts
questions comments confusions
No okay so let's take a 10-minute break
and then we'll come back into the second
bar okay so equipped with these five
tricks I want to actually talk about
generative model it's the topic that
we're here to talk about and I'm going
to talk specifically about two types of
models prescribed and implicit models
this is the way I split thinking about
generative model so who wants to tell me
what density estimation is anyone once
the volunteer and explanation what is
density estimation no takers today good
guess shot from the back okay so we're
going to look a little bit about density
estimation people don't talk about
density ation density estimation that
much so let's talk a bit about models
see you have typically you have been
looking at conditional models so when
you are building a classifier you are
doing supervised learning it is a
conditional model because it is a P of Y
conditioned on some other observed
variable X right and typically these
kind of models are called regression
models or classification models or in
the most generic sense conditional
density estimation and I'll I'll say
what density estimation is then the
other side is to not be conditional is
to do unconditional models so that's
typically what people mean when they say
supervised learning you want to learn P
of X like someone said at the back
earlier there's no targets there's no
labels and typically a generative model
is meant an unconditional model but even
that you know it's not it's not
something you should really live by I
guess the key point of this is to know
that they are conditional and
unconditional models and these are the
things we're going to be building but
that every probabilistic model in some
form of the other is a generative model
and I'm just pointing this out is that
generative model can be an odd word to
use it can be an odd statement may be
meaningless at some point in time so
just always think about and clarify as
to what we're going to mean so we're
going to talk about
generative models of particular Pines
right so the first thing to think about
is density estimation when you did your
first thinking about statistics and
probability then you were exposed to
this idea of the density of data and
knowing its probability and you did that
kind of density estimation by histograms
by kernel density estimation then later
on came PCA and factor analysis and then
mixture models came so these were the
basic tools of density estimation and
they were any way of learning about the
probability density P of X from observed
data and all we're going to do is
continue in this tradition and build
richer models that are going to help us
deal with really complex data so when a
generative model can mean various
different things
many people will refer to a generative
model by this word to generate so a
model that allows us to learn a
simulator of data right so in that case
you can simulate you can generate and a
model that lets you do that then is a
generative model for some other people
you will talk about a model for density
estimation and that will be a generative
model so if you are learning P of X in
some way or some high dimensional P of X
then that will be it and for other
people will be just anything that is
unsupervised will also be a generative
model in some some way or the other so
you can choose whichever definition that
you like but typically the
characteristics that's come between all
of them is that there are probabilistic
models that have some form of
uncertainty some form of distribution
that we're going to be manipulating
typically we're always going to target
the distribution of the data P of X
either directly or indirectly and the
keeping I think that makes it a
generative model rather than just
calling to classify is that you have
very high dimensional output so a
classifier has very low dimensional
output it's 1 in binary classification
1,000 for imagenet but it's not more
than that whereas P of X or generative
models are entire images entire
sequences of events entire speech
signals so these are sort of some of the
definitions
so I will always encourage people to
think about machine learning in as built
up of three components you have models
and models are the thing that you used
to describe the world that you use to
describe the data that you're actually
dealing with and to describe your
problem it will put all your domain
knowledge or the ways of things you
think you should represent knowledge in
the world and that will be what you have
in your model now you also have data
which came from the problem that you are
thinking about and then we have learning
principles and learning principles are
those things that connect the data that
you have with the model that you have
specified and you need this thing that
helps you interface these two things and
so you will always have these learning
principles and then for any choice of
model and for any choice of learning
principle you can then put those
together to form an algorithm and even
an algorithm you can form in very for
even the same model and the same
principle of learning you can create
many different kinds of algorithms and I
think if you keep this structured point
of view in mind that is how you will see
the connections like we did in all those
tricks to every other area of
statistical science whether that is in
computational neuroscience or in
probability theory or in operations
research or even in machine learning and
that is how we will see that things are
the same used in different ways and how
we can actually learn those tricks from
other fields to make our own world
better so I want to talk just a little
bit about models there are two types of
models that will break them into one are
the fully observed models so fully
observed models are models that you
build based on the data that you see
only right so they introduce no
unobserved variables and so here you
have a undirected graphical model with a
threeway factor that is an unobserved
graphical is a model of both the machine
is another kind of model of that form or
you have these kind of auto regressive
models care order regress auto
regressive models they are fully
observed they only for build
dependencies based on observed data and
things that you can actually measure in
the world then you have latent variable
models and latent variable models do
that the opposite of that they introduce
other variables which cannot be observed
in the world but which we can learn
about based on the data that we have
seen and latent variable models are both
of these are equally popular machine
learning and undulation variable models
will have two different kinds of latent
variable models one will be the
prescribed models and prescribed models
are models where you will decide that
the observational data that you have has
some kind of likelihood function there
is a noise model and by choosing a noise
model say in this graphical model we
have a random variable Z which is
unobserved and then we have a new random
variable X which itself has some
distribution that we choose and this is
a lot of knowledge that we add we
basically say that we can know something
about the probability that this data X
has in the world even if it's just
saying that it has Gaussian noise that
is a useful amount of knowledge and that
is the likelihood function that we write
in all other areas of statistics and
machine learning and this is why this
prescribed models are basically
likelihood based methods of estimation
right and similarly up at the top
they are also prescribed in this sense
that the observed models also use
likelihood functions and they are they
are prescribed but implicit models they
basically use this trick of the change
of variables that we discussed earlier
they take a random variable Z and
transform it through some function f and
that is what they say they say that you
can simulate data instead and so these
models are sometimes called likelihood
free models so if you are reading in
biostatistics you will often see this
expression of likelihood free estimation
and likelihood free model so we're going
to look at this but most of the time
we'll spend talking about latent
variable models so when it comes to
learning principles you now have a whole
plethora of learning principles to
choose from the first ones that you
exposed to what the exact methods where
you did enumeration of all the
probabilities using a probability table
or you learnt about conjugate
exponential family models where you
could do things in closed form you also
did in numerical methods numerical
integration for simple one-dimensional
maybe two dimensional integrals you
computed the integrals exactly other
methods like the generalized method of
moments maximum likelihood maximum
a-posteriori laplace estimation
and so on and on and on so many and many
more being added all the time and
hopefully you would have seen at least a
little bit of all of these different
kinds of methods but we all look at
maximum likelihood expectation
maximization variational methods and
well I should update this list we'll
look at one other thing which well just
generically called non maximum
likelihood so things which live outside
this list so now you get to choose one
of your models and you get to choose
literally any one of these learning
principles and then that's how you will
fuse your data in with your model and
then you will be able to build an
algorithm of some sort so this is where
everything comes on so let's go through
four different cases so that you
understand this thing so you can take a
convolution on your own network this is
a model this model encodes the fact that
we want to model images images have
certain translational properties and
because of those invariance and
translational properties we will use
convolution so that's what goes into the
model we're going to choose to do
penalize maximum likelihood
so that is maximum likelihood with
penalty Ridge regression methods or map
map estimation which is core and then
you get to build an algorithm in various
different ways you get to choose what
kind of optimization that you get are
you going to use some precondition
optimizer are you going to use some
stochastic optimized are you going to
use a batch method like BFGS you can
choose what kind of penalization you
will use whether it's l2 r1 what other
kinds of regularization you are at and
all of these will build very different
kinds of algorithms that you will test
and this is the thing that you're doing
sweeps over when you're doing
experiments let's look at this one which
are we won't talk about today you have
the restricted Boltzmann machine which
is the latent variable model and it's
undirected and you can do maximum
likelihood estimation to learn the
parameters which live in these arrows
and there are various different kinds of
algorithms that you can create you can
solve that by doing contrastive
divergence which is built based on
building a Markov chain to sample the
Z's given X you can do a variation of
that called persistent contrasted
divergence you can do other ways of
manipulating the gradients by tempering
and natural gradients and the two things
we are going to look at today are latent
variable models
Plus variational inference that we can
build many different algorithms we can
create a variation of the e/m algorithm
we can do another algorithm call
expectation propagation we can do other
simplifications call approximate message
passing more recently we've creates
things call variational autoencoders and
then with the implicit generator model
setting we can do the same thing we can
use two sample testing as our learning
principle and then we can create many
different algorithms based on what we
have based a method of moments using
approximate Bayesian computation or the
way we do it in generative adversarial
networks but all of these take the same
model the same inference and then end up
with very different looking algorithms
but they're not actually that different
right they may behave different have
different kind of use cases but they are
they have a lot to share with each other
so let's talk about different types of
generative models and when you want to
build a generative model there will be
several design dimensions you want to
think about the thing is like how will
you choose your model and choose your
corresponding principles you will need
to think about the data that you have
whether the data is binary whether it is
real valued whether it's some mixture of
the two whether they have some ordering
involved in the data and that data is
going to affect how you will design your
model you will need to think about the
dependency structure in that data can
you assume that you just have a set of
images that are all independent or iya
dealing with the time series in which
case there is a temporal structure which
you need to account for or are we
dealing with some maps where we're
modeling bird movements or forest fires
and then there's a spatial aspect that
we have to deal with you need to think
about elements of the representation
that were gee are those latent variables
we will introduce or unobserved
variables or dealing with the causality
continuous or the discrete or there's
some mixed are the continuous-time on
the discrete-time and then we the last
one is often to think about the kind of
dimensionality we want to deal with are
we going to deal with parametric
functions and parametric models which
means we're going to build very large
functions with lots of parameters that
we're going to choose by optimization or
are we going to do some other kind of
methods which are nonparametric infinite
dimensional that will rely on the data
to inform the kind of predictions or
inferential questions that we ask and
then you have other kind
the things which really affect your
decision-making the computational
complexity the modeling capacity that
they have whether there's bias whether
you need uncertainty how well calibrated
those models are as it they represent
the probability of the data that you saw
whether your model is interpretable to
humans or not all of these things matter
and there is a generative model that you
can decide and design based on what your
needs are so the first kind of
generative model have these fully
observed models and as they said a fully
observed model deals on the data
directly and they don't introduce any
other variables other than what is
observed so here is a chain of data and
the data is just dependent only another
data point and of course all the arrows
represent some kind of functions and I
just want to make a distinction between
two different things we call sometimes
these model parameters we'll call them
global parameters global parameters are
things which are relevant to all data
points that you see and often you will
talk about local variables or local
parameters and local variables and local
parameters are something which are
specific to individual data points so
typically parameters theta of your model
are something you learn over the whole
data set but you will learn latent
variables em4 data point xn so this is
this distinction between local and
global variables and so one kind are
fully observed models are Markov models
they will start with some X 1 with a
categorical distribution then you above
build an autoregressive chain we'll say
X 2 is the categorical distribution
conditioned on X 1 with some function pi
and so on and so forth until you reach X
I this is one of the most children the
oldest model probably in all of
computational thinking people have won
Nobel prizes for building a model like
this right and so very important and
very powerful and then you can write the
joint probability as simply the product
of I or P of x given all previous FS and
depending on what she chooses F if F
allows you to do some variable order you
can build infinite dimensional or K
order autoregressive models and you can
condition these kind of models on other
external quantity
and what for example in economics you'll
hear is called these narcs models and
nonlinear auto regressive models with
exogenous variables if you've seen those
these are all these models but for the
case that I am thinking of the case that
many people do these days all these
functions are for PI R builds by deep
neural networks so that you can actually
build and learn Mis cannibal way so
fully observed models have several
properties as I said because they are
fully observed they directly encode how
data points are observed in the world
which means you don't need to make too
many assumptions about what's going on
any data type can be used whether it's
discrete or continuous or even a mixed
and if you're building a directed
graphical model like the graphs that I
was just showing where there is the
arrow of dependency then parameter
learning is going to be very simple you
can write up the log likelihood that we
wrote there before and then you just
need to take simply the gradient and
that is the easiest thing you can do you
know the log likelihood exactly and you
can do that fast and you can scale this
out to very large models then you have
lots of different kind of optimization
and lots of different applications over
time but of course there is this order
which were using things in and so
there's an order sensitivity which is
coming in and if we were dealing with
directed models then think undirected
models and that's much more difficult
because parameter learning in undirected
models is very difficult because we need
to know the normalizing constant it's
not known as in the directed case and
generation can be very slow in either of
these models because we need to go
through the sequential process of
simulating from the Markov chain but
when you do do that for example one
model called pixel CNN and it has now
various kinds of instantiation thus far
can give you like really amazing
unconditional samples or conditional
samples in this case that really sure it
has learnt to date on and really can do
amazing things so if you want to look at
sort of the space of different kinds of
models then one way to think of there
would be along an axis of directed
models versus undirected graphical
models and another axis of continuous
variables versus discrete variables and
then you in any quadrant that you choose
you can find a kind of fully observed
model
across any any area of statistical
science so let's choose a good block so
here's a good one
undirected graphical models with
continuous variables for example many of
you would have studied thousand mrs
which are Markov random field and then
these are models there and then you can
learn about all the things in this they
are long linear models as they're
sometimes call people don't work in this
space anymore of discrete and undirected
models but both of machines are there
Ising models hopfield networks parts
models live in this case but where most
people work in this case is in the
discrete and directed case this images
can be represented between 0 and 255 and
so that's discrete and you can build
made fully visible sigmoid belief
networks this pixel CNN which I just
described to you any RNN language model
that people brought which in this
category and other models which live
outside even of more the mainstream like
context-free switching algorithms that
live in this space so so a lot of fun
fun models and to explore in this in
this space so then we'll go to the
second part which are these latent
variable months the latent variable
model introduced and unobserved and what
we'll call local random variables so
instead of only X there's now another
variable said and that is something you
can't measure but said is something very
powerful because introducing said a
helps you understand issues around the
causal structure of the data and the
world that you're dealing in and it
allows you to build very complex
dependency structures so you don't need
to design the dependency structure by
hand you can introduce the Z integrated
out and then it will induce the
dependency structure in X which is the
thing you actually want to have and so
here's one kind of model which is called
a deep latent Gaussian model it's a
directed graphical model it has several
layers of latent variables which are
stochastic hidden layers and then you
connect them through deep networks in
any way that she likes
example z3 from a Gaussian you can
sample z2 conditioned on z3 from a
Gaussian with parameters mu and Sigma
that are functions of the previous Z and
we can create a tree a hierarchy in this
case and then finally we'd get your
final the observed data where we choose
a likelihood function when this
case it is a Gaussian but it can be
anything can be Bernoulli distribution
for binary data can be a multinomial
distribution if we had some form of
categorical data and it can be products
for mixed mixed kind of distributions or
non-negative quantities so latent
variable models have very different
properties they have very easy sampling
because you can just follow this tree
and then you can start from dead tree
generates it to generate said one get
the sampling they're an easy way to
include this hierarchical structure or
depth into your model and it's easy to
encode the structure that you believe in
the world so for example physicists
actually do have knowledge about how
they think the image of the galaxy
appearing on the telescope appears how
every pixel appears and you can put that
knowledge in build a graphical model
very similar to what what I just showed
you in the previous slide and you avoid
this order dependency that we saw
because marginalization this integration
of the latent variables induces
dependencies and latent variables have a
different interpretation if you are
thinking putting your hat on from
information theory or from compression
theory as a compression or
representation of the data and I guess
one of the important things is that we
always want to do model scoring we want
to do model comparison we want to choose
the best model for the problem that we
have and being able to compute the
marginalize likelihood is what we can do
in latent variable models but what is
difficult is that you need to know these
latent variables and to be able to do
any of these things and that inversion
process is very hard it can be difficult
to compute the marginalize likelihood
which is why we need all the tricks from
part one and it may not be easy to
specify because you need to know these
sort of going back to this inversion
process you may have to choose the kind
of family of approximations and that can
be hard to do but in when you do that
you can build very flexible and powerful
latent variable models of images for
example and this is a model called draw
so we'll just quickly look at this one
but again there are lots of different
dimensions for which you can build a
model you can choose linear models
versus deep models you can choose
parametric models versus non parametric
models you can choose continuous latent
variables versus discretely
variable and then you can build sort of
lots of different models in different
cases so maybe something you haven't
thought of or seen before these deep
nonparametric and discrete models so
there are lots of models in this case
one example what they call cascaded
Indian buffet processes which are now a
sequence basically of discrete infinite
dimensional distributions of a binary
object or if you've heard of a something
called Jewish lay process then you can
build a hierarchical darshan a process
which is the nonparametric extension of
a model call Lda that lives in that
corner or the Mun we are actually going
to look at today are deep parametric and
continuous latent variables nonlinear
factor analysis nonlinear Gaussian
belief networks and all these deep
latent gaussian models like v AE the v
AE algorithm in draw so we're going to
look at that but lots of other models to
look at and I just want to highlight
separately from the latent variable
models which I just described to these
implicit models implicit models are
simulators they transform an unobserved
source of noise into data using a
parametrized function f so we saw this
picture before when we looked at their
path wise gradients in the pathways
estimation this is exactly of that form
we choose some source of noise and then
we choose a path through which to
transform that noise and because we will
know F we're going to manipulate F and
use the knowledge that we have to learn
its parameters and learn a generative
model in this way and again we're going
to use the change of variables will be
the central quantity that will exploit
when we do this and the model that most
people see today is this one here which
is the generator network from DC Gann
and which just simply starts is choosing
a Gaussian latent variable and then you
create a function f which is this deep
continent which actually grows art and
image but the function f can literally
be anything can be a linear function can
be a deep neural network can be a
recurrent model like in El STM it can be
a non parametric function like a
sequence of Gaussian processes lots of
different things he can use implicit
models have different properties and
some they are also easy to sample and
easy to specify because you can just
write out this function f it's very easy
to compute the expectations we
because all you need to do is just
sample from the noise and generate from
the function and then you basically can
take averages over the samples and it's
very easy to exploit large scale
classifiers in confidence when you
design those functions but if you had
any constraints like these functions if
they needed to be invertible if there
were other kinds of constraints you
needed to do then an optimization can be
very difficult and the invertibility may
be hard to maintain there isn't this
likelihood which seems to be an
advantage but is sometimes a
disadvantage because not having a
likelihood model is what causes you to
be unstable during optimization and to
not learn the correct probability
density but the main reason is that you
can't extend to generic data types if
your function is continuous the data you
generate is continuous if your function
is discrete you will generate discrete
data but well you won't be able to
handle discrete data and it's very hard
to compute the marginalization and your
model scoring in this case but again
lots of different things to consider the
one we are going to look at on this time
we're going to look at functions that
operate in discrete time but you could
also easily look at these kind of
implicit models which are diffusions
based in continuous time so we're going
to look at one line sampling
transformations which we looked at in
the earlier trick normalizing flows fits
into this which we won't discuss today
and generator networks in ganz and
volume and non volume preserving
optimizations but you've already seen
some of these if you looked at the
launch of is de or Hamiltonian
Montecarlo or you know simple physical
sarcastic differential equations okay I
want to talk about influence in
prescribe models so these are models
with latent variable with the likelihood
function so the model evidence are the
marginal likelihood or the partition
function is the key quantity we will be
interested in and that means we want to
integrate out Z to know P of x1 and the
learning principle of knowing the
bayesian model evidence is that all we
want to do is at every step of
optimization every time we look at our
data we want to make sure that this
model evidence becomes maximized we want
the maximum evidence the highest
probability of data that we can possibly
have and that's why optimizing the model
evidence is the principle for learning
and so that's the principle we if we
have these latent variables we want to
integrate said to know P of X and once
we know P of X we're going to maximize
it to try and get to learn the best
model possible of course there's an
integral which is very difficult to
compute so maybe some of our tricks will
be useful here and the basic idea is to
transform this integral which is an
integral of an expectation of some
distribution into an expectation of a
distribution that we choose and once we
can choose that distribution then we can
be more flexible all right so we've seen
that before we use the identity trick
and Jensen's inequality to derive this
lower bound on the marginal likelihood
and as I said this marginal likelihood
is called the variational free-energy
and it's the basis of what we will call
variational inference which is one of
the most popular methods for doing
inference in latent variable models and
it is called the variational free-energy
because I chose to introduce this
distribution Q and I'm free to choose
the distribution Q that allows me to
best match the model likelihood and so
what I'm gonna have to do here is learn
something about Q but I also have to
learn what about P where's the model the
model that I'm actually interested in
and as I said it's sometimes called the
evidence lower bound because it is a
bound on the model or the data evidence
and I said we need to choose true in the
two tricks we used here with identity
trick and the bounding trick so this
just lets me allow you to explain in
general what the variational principle
is a variational principle is just a
family of methods that allows you to
approximate something difficult with
something simple right and by being
variational that word variation you can
substitute it with the word functional
it is an optimization in a functional
space right so here some complicated
distribution this distribution is the
density and the density is a function
special kind of function and so this is
a variational problem because I'm going
to choose an approximating class of
functions and it is variational because
I'm going to try and find the best
function to match that function and you
can do this directly using functional
gradient descent which is what we call
the variational calculus but we're going
to try and avoid the variational
calculus because we can actually put
ramit rise these distributions through
other parameters file and that means we
can do parametric optimization or
standard optimization and the parameters
Phi right so this is in general which is
why even though this is called
variational inference there are lots of
things which are variational methods in
fact reinforcement learning is itself a
variational method because the policies
PI are these functions which are doing a
functional descent over or you know
they're many all of information theory
fits into this kind of thing and
building lots of other bounds lets you
build variational methods so just be
flexible there are lots of very few
methods that exist out there and we want
to fit these variational parameters Phi
so in very tional inference there are
two terms there's this first term which
is a log likelihood of log P of x given
that this is the model you get to choose
so this is for example a Gaussian
distribution in which case this is an l2
loss and then you get a penalty term
which is going to say that this
distribution Q that I have chosen should
be something close to my prior PI and
this is good because this is a penalized
way of doing learning and we always want
to have regularizes and the other thing
that's useful is that you didn't need to
design the regularizer just by applying
the variational principle and applying
these two tricks I likelihood a
reconstruction term appeared but also
the correct and you know
regularization appeared and this
distribution Q that we introduced which
was when we did importance sampling was
just some generic distribution was a
proposal now this distribution Q has a
meaning it is a posterior distribution
it is something that tries to invert the
probability it tries to give you the
probability of Z given X so in all the
slides that's here before the notation
is a bit sloppy
you should read Zed given X here and
I'll try and fix them when I put that on
line so again Q of Z tries to match the
true posterior P of Z given Y and P of
knowing P of Z given Y is one of the
useful information quantities and then
you have a reconstruction cost which I
talked about and then a natural penalty
which is the mechanism for Occam's razor
now just some comments on this
distribution Q by having this problem Y
was an ugly integral is now enough to
problem because we can just how use this
is the last function and there are two
types of parameters there are parameters
theta which live in P and there are
parameters Phi which live in Q and these
are the two things you need to optimize
and so this is now much easier problem
to do as I said I've been writing Q of Z
but it actually depends on the data and
sometimes I'm using X and sometimes I'm
using Y sorry for that and you have easy
convergence assessments because this is
a bound every time you do an improvement
the bound can only go in one direction
it must go up and so you'll be able to
this is how you can actually plot while
you are testing this and then you have
purel parameters of cubes in okay so the
key thing here I want to just switch to
talking about this distribution Q of Z
so cubes there was something you had to
choose and as I said it is something
that's trying to match the true
posterior distribution which is said
given X this probability of Z given X so
what do real-world distributions
posterior distributions look like so
here's an example that was made on M
NIST in two dimensional latent variables
and by enumeration I'm just going to
show you what the real posterior
distribution for certain kinds of simple
models look like so here's a simple
model it has two latent variables it's
simple one layer with a Gaussian output
and the what is the real distribution is
the gray thing so you just need to look
at the gray thing it's the same in each
kernel it's just a different zoom levels
and what are blue are samples from this
Q distribution which we sample from
after training this method so you can
see in some cases you can't see because
of the light but some cases you can do
really well the blue can overlap the
white really well you can actually learn
the real distribution and in fact you
can even learn it when it has the strong
correlation structure you can do that
but this is the model I think with the
sigmoid non-linearity in there in the
network but when you start doing other
kinds of things you get weird blobs like
this or you get this one has at an age
it's a surface that has a sharp thing
like this and then carries on or you
have something that looks like this
which has a period of very high mass and
then a very long tail now if you were to
choose a queue
as a Gaussian it won't be able to learn
this this this this basically it's going
to struggle and you can sort of hear it
does well because you can do Gaussian
ish things but it's cut off on the other
side and so real whopper series even in
simple cases are complicated and when we
have high dimensional data they're even
more complicated so then we need to have
ways of designing these Q distributions
that are very flexible and efficient and
that is one of the ongoing areas of
research and so you basically have a
spectrum of things to choose around this
Q you have on one side Q star which is
the optimal posterior distribution which
is just the result of Bayes rule P of X
given Z times P of Z you can never know
this because if you knew the truth you
wouldn't do any of this so this side you
can't get to the exact opposite end is
where you choose that everything is
independent and what we call the fully
factorize this is the least expressive
way to design a q function but very
popular so you can just do the product
over K dimensions of individual
univariate gaussians for example right
and then in between there's a lot of
different things so this is where we
want to be able to build these deep rich
distributions and so what lives in
between are things which are called
structured approximations they introduce
some kind of dependency structures they
can see Zed K is dependent on some
subset of all others ads in the model
and this is where you can do a lot of
things and sometimes you'll hear people
say structured mean filled in the data
and all the times not so I thought we'd
do a very simple example so here's a
model which has a Gaussian latent
variable said it has a likelihood
function which I'm leaving generic but
you can assume it's a Gaussian or
Bernoulli distribution and then I'm
choosing a Q distribution which is a
product of univariate gaussians said I
given mu I and Sigma I and so what we do
is we draw it out a variational lower
bound and then we would substitute in
here this care because the products over
and things actually becomes the sum of
Cal's for each of the individual terms
then you can write out the KL between
two gaussians or the KL between any two
exponential family distributions is
actually known in closed form you can
actually do this as an exercise for
yourself to derive the kr between two
distribution
and you'll see it will have a form like
this it will be a squared error
reconstruction term and then we'll have
some variance correction which is based
on the on the log log variance and then
you can get the log likelihood that you
always expect so if this is a Gaussian
you get an l2 error you get the l2 loss
here so you can do lots of things to
choose the Q because even here you still
I chose this Q as this product of
univariate gaussians but maybe that's
not a good thing to do so you can do
lots of things in between you can do
mixture models and mixture models is a
very popular one or you can just choose
to build gaussians with much more richer
covariance function there's many papers
and building rich covariance models for
Gaussian distributions you can build
structured mean feel they can build it
basically an auto regressive model so
all the other models that we learnt
about they can be used to design new
posterior approximations or you can
create other kinds of things these two
are relation of Xillia variable models
or normalizing flow methods and I have
lots of references at the end if for
anyone who wants to look at them so the
last bit is just look at the
optimization of this kind of loss
function so there are many different
ways of doing the optimization the
classical way was to do what is called
the variational e/m algorithm and then
to do stochastic versions of that where
we can subsample and use many batches of
data instead then more recently what
came was this idea of doubly stochastic
variational inference and I'll explain
the couples with this idea of amortized
inference which is the one that most
people use today so in the variational
problem and in in an e/m algorithm if
you recall what an e/m algorithm is
you're going to do an alternating
optimization between model parameters
theta and variational parameters Phi
right so an e/m algorithm when you write
it in code always looks as follows you
write a for loop for I equals 1 to n
then you write a function for the e step
and the e step itself has a for loop
where you compute you compute the
gradient with respect to all the
variational parameters Phi say e step is
about expectation and the expectation
you want is about the Q distribution so
these are the distributions are the
parameters of the Q distribution and
then you come to the M step
as the optimization with respect to the
model parameters which are Tisa and
because this is the bound like nem
algorithm every time you do one setting
of updating theta and Phi you improve
the bound until you reach a point where
you can't do that anymore and you
inherit this by using variational
inference because the variational bound
is also a quantity that is convergent
this way and the idea of just to know
this is that the classical idea of e/m
algorithm is that you have a model P and
approximate distribution Q you go in and
you do the key step the East step which
is to evaluate the expectation under
that distribution Q and in the classical
way you always assume you can compute
this integral exactly and analytically
and if it's known to you analytically
you use that result to compute the
gradient so this is what every ml Gotham
looks like this is difficult because now
we're gonna have to invent thousands of
new tricks just to solve this this
integral here and by inventing new more
and more tricks we get situations that
are less and less generic and much more
specialized so in some sense that's not
the right direction to do we want to see
if we can create generic ways of doing
that and just to jump to the end we're
gonna try and swap these two things
using the two tricks that we had earlier
so let's talk about amortized inference
and just stay at the e/m algorithm a
little bit more right so the e/m Elger
them again this is the algorithm it has
an e step for i equals 1 to n so you go
through every data point and for every
data point you optimize this variational
bound and you solve for every data point
and you find variational parameters Phi
N and you do this again for every data
point and then once you solve n
optimizations and you have n sets of
parameters then you go to the M step and
then you compute this average which is
an average over n data point so the
problem now is that with this e step
what you have to do is you are solving
the optimization for every data point
afresh you never reuse what you just did
for data point n minus 1 and you won't
use what you will do for data point n
plus 1 so this seems wasteful and
some sense you can think of this
classical Estep is something that is
like memory lists it doesn't use the
knowledge of other kinds of Estep
computation to inform the estep
computation for data point M and so what
we want to do is remove that sort of
deficiency in some sense and introduce
an idea of memory and this is where this
idea of introducing what they call an
inference network or a recognition model
is what we do is now we build some new
model we'll call this thank you and it
will have a global set of parameters Phi
it won't have parameters Phi n for every
data point will have one set of
parameters Phi that will apply to all
the data points right and that's the
point of having these inference networks
and the parameters of Q are now no
longer global per data point parameters
that you have to do optimization for
there are actually a global set of
parameters that are applicable to both
training and test time and the reason
it's called an amortized inference is
that this new set of global parameters
is what you use to spread the cost of
the inference over all the data points
you get to do sometimes what they call
sharing statistical strengths where you
use all the other data points inference
to help inform your own inference and so
the joint are and then by having this
kind of inference network you no need to
do an EML Gotham you don't need to
alternate between model parameters and
variational parameters because there are
only global parameters you can do joint
optimization of all of them
simultaneously right so the idea of
inference networks or anyplace where you
see this element of some kind of encoder
appearing is that it gives you an
efficient mechanism to learn kind of
posterior distributions where you have
this kind of memory component where you
can't share knowledge between different
data points so let's put very rational
inference and amortize inference
together and so we have this approximate
posterior distribution Q which we need
to design in truth we have a
reconstruction term which is going to
give us the fidelity of how well we are
learning the data we see and we have the
penalty term to do Occam's razor
now we implement a stochastic encoder
decoder system so our model is
effectively a decoder it takes latent
variable Z
through some kind of model and generates
data exa it is a generative model and
then we have a recognition model or an
inference Network which states data X
through another set of global parameters
and gives us samples from this set Q in
fact the two things that this model
needs to do it needs to be able to give
you samples and you need to tell you
what the entropy just what log Q is
doesn't need to do anything else so when
you code a class for these kind of
distributions as long as the
distribution can have dot sample and dot
entropy or dot log problem that's all
you need to basically implement these
two things so again as I said the
decoder is a likelihood model the
inference is now dealt with by this
encoder or variational distribution and
what this also does when you can see
this it transforms an auto encoder which
is a deterministic function which is not
probabilistic in this way into a
generative model because now you can
actually sample from it by just sampling
from Z and then generating data right
and so this specific combination again
going back to that principle of machine
learning that I asked you to think about
we chose a latent variable model ik Zed
and you chose a principle of inference
which is based on variational inference
and you implemented it using amortized
inference with the recognition model
that thing together is an algorithm and
that algorithm is today called a
variational auto encoder please don't
call it the very short encoder model a
little part of me will die so never do
that that is wrong BAE
is an algorithm because it defines a
full set of computation of computational
graph for dealing with data learning its
posterior distribution and doing its
optimization together so never forget
what the model is it is a latent
variable model what the principle of
inference is you use variational
inference you can replace that with
almost anything else that you like and
we'll do that now in the next step and
then how you put it together was by
using this inference network on
amortized inference but we could have
easily solve this by variational e/m or
Monte Carlo e/m or hybrid Monte Carlo
sampling or several other methods so ok
we are running out of time so I'm just
quickly going to say a little bit about
the stochastic gradient estimation again
here's that famous problem that came
where we had two tricks earlier we need
to compute the gradient of an integrand
with respect to some function and in the
e/m algorithm we had first compute the
integral then compute the gradient and
what we're going to do now is we're
going to swap the gradient with the
integral first and the way we can do
that swapping of the greater an integral
is to exactly use those two tricks that
we had
you can either compute this gradient by
the pathways estimator using a ripper
ammeter ization trick or you use the
score function estimator by applying the
identity and the log derivative tricks
right and so you get these two ways of
doing estimation both of them are
equally valid and what will inform your
choice will be again how you design your
model f so for example if you were
working computer graphics and your model
you didn't want to write a model you
actually wanted to put a renderer
graphics render as the model then you
wouldn't be able to differentiate
through the renderer not in general
though they are differentiable renderers
so then the only thing you could do is
to do this model but if you were doing a
more statistical approach where we were
understanding the biology of the genetic
tree and we actually built that model
then we would know about f we could
differentiate and then that would be
maybe the better approach to take so
those are called doubly stochastic so in
the last ten minutes I just want to
quickly talk about estimation about
comparison and learning in implicit
generative model so in implicit
generative models you have a simulator
from some data points from some random
source said through this function f and
it can just simulate data X and the
tasks that you have to do is compare
samples from your data model which I'm
going to call Q with the true data
distribution which is P star and this is
a classical problem in statistic which
is called the two sample testing problem
you have two sets of samples you need to
compare them in some way and we will
actually want to do one step more than
what statisticians we would do we also
want to do learning of our model
parameter so we're gonna do need to do a
little bit more and so all we need to do
is find ways to compare distributions
and there are either two things you can
do you can either compute P divided by Q
and if P divided by Q is one that is the
definition of learning because then
you've learned the data point or you can
say P minus Q and if he minus Q is zero
then you've also lunch right so these
are the two principles of learning
involved here and you can do both of
them
if we had an hour we could just talk
about this one slide as different ways
of do a density ratio versus density
difference estimation so let's at the
high level talk about this estimation by
comparison always involves two steps
it's exactly like the e/m algorithm
before you have a testing step or a
comparison step where you're first going
to find something some tools some trick
that helps you compare one sample of
data with another and to say how close
it is or how different it is and once
you have that thing which tells you how
close are different that's exactly like
gradient and then you can use that to
learn so then you can do the learning
step or the adjustment step and so here
you have the hypothesis is either that
the two distributions are the same or
the two are different and you're going
to try and find some loss function f as
I said you can do this by density
difference methods by looking at P minus
Q and lots of methods and the maximum
mean discrepancy optimal transport
moment matching are going to fit into
this category I'm not going to talk
about that today and then you can either
look at P divided by Q which is the
density ratio method and we can do this
either by class probability estimation
because we looked at that as a one
specific trick but there are other
methods based and Bragman divergences
and F divergences that we can solve that
instead so this is sort of in general
view of that landscape so let's just
look at adversarial learning in
adversarial learning we're going to look
at this ratio of P divided by Q and
based on the density ratio trick we know
that we can solve ratios like this by
building classifiers instead our
generative model will be sampled from
some base distribution like a Gaussian
and generate this to some function f
like a conflict to generate samples and
then we're going to need to do
comparison right and so the comparison
is to build this classifier that's what
the density ratio trick is so how do you
actually compute P of y equals 1 given X
you need to build a classifier and
that's in the statistical language
called building a scoring function so
you're going to build a scoring function
which is going to tell you what the
probability of y equals plus 1 is and
the probability of y equals minus 1 is
just 1 minus that probability because
they must sum to 1 and then now that you
have this you can assign a Bernoulli
loss you can say I want things
I want data that's under queue to be
seen as the negative class and data
that's frumpy to be seen as the positive
class and that's how you'll actually
learn this scoring function with that
and you can use any sort of scoring
functions you don't only need to use the
bernoulli you can replace this with the
squared loss in which case is called a
breyer loss and you can replace it with
several other losses their entire papers
just on choosing scoring functions and
how you can choose the best scoring
function depending on the problem you
have so this kind of idea has lots of
different names and the most generic
name it has been given it's called
unsupervised as supervised learning and
you can see that we wanted to do this
unsupervised learning and what we first
had to do was build this classifier so
that is the supervised part and that's
unsupervised supervised learning I
mentioned earlier in the approximate
Bayesian computation literature they've
also had this idea of building a
classifier to decide moments or ways of
comparing two data points and then
learning a Monte Carlo sample that's
called classify ABC non-controlled north
contrastive estimation is a way of doing
non maximum likelihood estimation like
all of this in this section is and so
that uses the same idea and then
adversarial learning in particular in
the way it appears in ganz uses also
exactly this principle so we have again
an alternating optimization between two
types of parameters you have model
parameters Phi and then parameters of
the scoring functions D right and in
adversarial networks you will call this
model the generator and you will call
this scoring function the discriminator
because it is a classifier and then you
have to just solve the optimization
between these two things so then again
you have the comparison loss which is
solve for the parameters of the
discriminator this is the thing that
tells you how close or how different
these two set of samples are and then
you have the generative loss who says
well based on the knowledge that I have
of D can I use that to give me a
gradient and how you actually get this
gradient is by using the remote ization
trick okay so that brings me to the end
the summary of today was to sort of give
you some of the tools to manipulate
probabilities and then use those tricks
and tools to manipulate probabilities to
then build all types of generative
models that you could imagine right and
we looked at different types of
generative models which were
undirected models fully observed models
models with latent variables I asked you
always to think about machine learning
within this three three prong approach
of thinking of models the corresponding
learning principles and the joint idea
of algorithms and the two examples we
used of that we said was bae was one
example of a model which was a latent
proscribed latent variable model with
variational inference which then gave us
a VA e algorithm and the other algorithm
we learnt about was ganz which use
implicit generative model as its model
it used this principle of two sample
testing as its principle of inference
and we put it together by building an
algorithm that used a repro motorisation
trick to actually do the optimization
and then we spoke about lots of other
things about stochastic optimization how
we can manipulate those integrals to do
a lot more scalable inference we spoke
about amortized inference and how
encoders typically ampere machine
learning and then how we can build lots
of different complex distributions over
data there's lots more to do almost
every one of these represents a
different topic for research whether it
is the last function itself whether it
is how you build these Q distributions
other ways of computing gradient
estimators understanding their variance
properties what are other ways of doing
non maximum likelihood learning you know
all of these represent a place of more
research which needs to be done and I
hope lots of you all will join us in
that effort so thank you for your
attention
you